so you're talking earlier about Google
TV and where are you or or where experts
to envision in about four years so i
think it's it's uh when you look at
what's going to have a netflix and hulu
where they're starting to make their own
shows and YouTube's dropping 150 million
dollars into YouTube or Google into
YouTube channels of all the same company
I think what is happening with the
ability to stream things under
television again with the behavior of
like I watch a lot of TV on hulu I
rarely watch live television ever I
absolutely don't even watch my actual
television that often anymore that is
that's a behavioral thing that changes
there's lots of internet connected TVs
out there that are not connected to the
internet that's going to change now that
you can string with a ps3 with a
Playstation with a xbox a tivo blu-ray
player now that netflix has shows that
you can only see on netflix and they're
bringing arrested development back and
they're shooting David Fincher's house
of games our house of cards hulu's has
battleground and a couple other shows
the the behavioral reality of
appointment television is dying it's
only really the American titles and that
sort of thing where this is all going is
that there will be no more networks in
the classic sense of the word in terms
of your brain because it's late the tivo
once you start doing tebow then it was
like well you just put your own network
together right now it's just a tsunami
of content that is just coming towards
everyone and more and more videos are
getting uploaded now it's going to be
about quality it's going to be about
what people like
but the reality of sitting down watching
a television show at a certain time is
over even with netflix they put out
Lillehammer which is a show they made
with norwegian television they put all
the episode they put the all season up
in one day because more television is
washing on netflix right now than movies
so they already know that's binge
viewing this idea of like sitting down
with all of sons of anarchy or all of
madmen and just watch episode after
episode that is a behavioral thing
that's happening so where this all ends
up is I think for an independent
storyteller if Hulu or Netflix puts a
show on the Internet and so we can
stream it to their television and you
put a story on YouTube and they can
stream it to their television what is
the difference between you and netflix
and hulu nothing it's just a Babylonian
marketing that's all they have I mean
it's a that's a nice thing to have but
the reality is that's sort of like
they're the Cineplex you know we're
still the indie theater down the street
that has the shitty popcorn but we're
both on the internet we're both can
stream to televisions so right now in
terms of the future there's no
difference between me and what they're
doing other than their giant machine
with money and marketing and and more
production value but the reality of all
this is that i can now like when you
made a film you'd have to go to a
festival get a distributor get it to a
theater now you can just put it on the
internet and more people see stuff on
the internet and more movies on their
television and streaming than the not so
why wouldn't why wouldn't you do that I
think that's where the future is it's
going to be a mess it's going to be
archaic it's going to be hard to figure
out where stuff is that's that's the
next thing and maybe Google TV will play
a part in helping people find things but
everything's going to be on the internet
independent stories network stories
there will be no more okay there's no
need for cable
let's it already authority building a
cable station on youtube that has more
channels than any cable system that
exists now so that's already happening
now it's really just about the
audience's behavior catching up to the
technology's ability it's already there
it's just the mindset of I'm going to
watch that on my computer or I'm going
to stream that to my television what
would you see is the time frame that
will be fully integrated eating I don't
know i I don't know it it it's not going
to be probably this year or next year I
think it's more about you know it
probably took say YouTube starts 0506
took maybe four years to get people to
start watching stuff on hulu and netflix
so maybe three four years something like
that
you